if you're a homeschooling mom to a preschooler
and you need something to do over the summer break
this is a great way to start our alphabet
we already do the good and beautiful preschool curriculum
but this is a great way to help my daughter practice her apple
case and lowercase letters
she absolutely loved that
it was ice cream which really engaged her
and the colours made it so much easier for her to focus
these are solid pieces the quality feels amazing
and they will last a lifetime
easy to clean and wipe down
and so much fun for the whole family to play with
do we mash all the letters up
we started lining them up in the alphabets
this also helped her get her alphabet down
I don't know why they're still in stock before the home school runs